[Music]
hey New York Times bestselling author
Erica Jane hey Bryce how does that feel
it feels incredible it feels it's unreal
I've exceeded all my expectations we are
in that be pretty mess clever this is
the clubhouse can we talk about why this
is the necessary space for America dream
well hey America Jamie and it's an
office my business grew and I needed to
get it away from my home and this is a
great spot LA traffic is terrible and I
come and I get ready for work and I go
it's a creative space at this point it's
expensive
[Music]
only et got an invite up to Erika Jaynes
a clubhouse this place pops for an
exclusive look inside the pretty mess
pad in the heart of Hollywood welcome to
the clubhouse let me give you a simple
quick little tour you know what's going
on over here okay so we have an open
kitchen obviously don't think I'm gonna
cook any meals in here this is probably
one of the more important parts of the
clubhouse look beautiful a Barbie Dream
closet kind of a little bit can we talk
through some of the fashions here so I'm
here it's funny because we have a
mishmash there's a couple of Erika Jayne
costumes that make sense and there's
this one that the Kim K avatar has on
here's another one from housewives
weekend house oh yes
legendary cat suits I say legendary cuz
they're legendary to me
I wore this some oh this is yeah we have
when I was getting for me and those are
the gloves from expensive there use it
the gloves from the video expensive just
happen to be here would you say the most
quintessentially Erika Jayne thing is
here on this rack or is it somewhere
else in this Clubhouse I mean this
definitely says Erica - Erica Chandler's
here yes that's who's here all right
come with me and I'll show you the glam
room yes this is you know where most of
it all takes place and this is in my
opinion what every woman should have I
mean we're on TV right are you ready for
me to like blast your face off
I think so one two three
Oh God it's a little intense in here if
you look good in this light you look at
anyone anywhere unless face ahd is no
one's friend no not even a fetus looks
good on HD because it's just really
intense no this is this is a good light
it's great even like all of these
drawers are filled with magical potions
and lotions and tools I was gonna say if
this was cribs this is where the magic
would happen not the bedroom here was
this the biggest investment in this
space the thing you had to have late
this was the where the where the money
is probably the products on here are
more expensive than the cabinetry
billion percent the things that are on
the Shelf are much more expense this is
thousands of dollars with them just
product product yeah thank you so to be
Erika Jayne it's expensive to be Glenn
all right go out there MA
come on out this way okay so let me show
you another part of this works they said
I really love I love this ceiling I'd
love to say I was responsible for it but
I'm not it's kind of great a lot of
great art gives the place a lot of
character already on the ceiling when
you move down that's feeling when I
moved in so I mean you know hey we got
biggie right here
biggie was one of the conditions of me
giving him space I said you know Big E
has to stay and then this was a great
little piece we blew it up and then I'll
show you the pretty mess neon which is
great and fun this kind of wraps up the
whole vibe around the whole vibe and
iconic at this point at this point I
think so I think this is pretty much it
yeah
well thanks for coming over thank you
for having us on the conference I love
it you're welcome anytime you're gonna
regret saying that no not
[Music]